so here's a straightforward question
what color are the strawberries in this
photograph they're red right wrong
those strawberries
are gray
if you don't believe me we look for one
of the reddest looking patches on this
image cut it out now
what color
is that
it's gray right but when you put it back
on the image
it's red again this illusion was created
by a japanese researcher named akiyoshi
kiraoka and it hinges on something
called color constancy it's an
incredible visual phenomenon by which
the color of an object appears to stay
more or less the same regardless of the
lighting conditions under which you see
it or the lighting conditions under
which your brain thinks you're seeing it